it's got a new novel out today called
hashtag me as well he is a longtime a
co-executive producer and writer of
Seinfeld episodes the man who brought
words like yadda-yadda and shrinkage
into our lexicon he is Peter Melman good
to see you sir thank you it's a pleasure
to be now this is about a Pulitzer Prize
winning sports columnist for The
Washington Post
um who's had decades of a great career
mostly blameless existence I'm reading
right here tosses out a characteristic
one-liner and then social media picks it
up joke goes viral and craziness ensues
is this about Tony Kornheiser no it is
not okay I think it's you know I started
out at the Washington Post in sports and
I think it's me if I had followed all
the rules and stayed at the post okay
you know like I fell all that time I had
covered teams and did everything and
became a columnist and that's where I am
like Tony like Tony yeah pretty much
it's you know it's it was my effort to
kind of take a humorous look at the at
the me to movement because it's such a
funny thing you know it's so ripe with
humor and that's why you went to it and
you know I checked me as well it's
actually kind of a funny story because
the joke he tells that gets him in
trouble is there he's sitting around
with a bunch of sports writers and
they're discussing a notoriously soft
NBA player let's say Charles Smith okay
very good
this player happens to be on the injured
list and so my guy in the book yes
jokingly says how long is a guy usually
out for a hysterectomy
and that's what goes Vaughn it goes the
joke goes viral and he gets caught up in
the me to movement because you know
people think it's incredibly sexist and
you know I mean I wanted to you know
kind of tightrope the law
between something that is actually funny
is borderline sexist but could be
interpreted you know it kind of walks a
line and here's the funny thing you'll
love about this I had that idea like 20
years ago
and when I was doing a show on ABC
called it's like you know hmm
I called up I called up Tommy Swami the
director of sports night right and said
I came up with this idea because these
ESPN guys you know they're constantly
trying to be so funny that what if one
of them goes too far right and he makes
that joke so I had that joke 20 years
ago and you know Tommy Swami says to me
don't you have your own show to do yes
sir
and I said yeah but you know we're on
the same network and I can't use that
idea but I thought it would be really
good for you guys so I'm being a team
player which I don't really like being
but I am being a team did not run it off
the Aaron Sorkin flagpole for not only
didn't run it up yeah I met an ABC party
a couple of weeks later and Aaron comes
up to me and says can I have a word with
you
mmm-hmm I'm like oh my god he was like
offended that I get and he goes that
idea you gave and you calling that was
the bleep biggest classy thing I have
ever heard I you know like that is so
classy and I said oh god I'm glad Aaron
but you know you got to get work on your
verbal cues you know you scared the hell
out of me I feel offended
so anyway lying around for 20 years you
know and now it's in hashtag me as well
you get the book that's that's available
starting today so also because you know
Tony from back of the day at the
Washington Post you worked on sports
beat with Howard Cosell for three years
yes I did what in the heck was that like
you had a good what's your favorite
Howard story Peter um my favorite Howard
story I'll tell you a you know the
fastest one okay speaking of me - oh no
no but this is
but this is Howard alright you know
nobody knows that how funny he was okay
he was incredibly funny and I'll tell
you one quick one is that you know we
interviewed Donald Trump up in his Tower
when he owned the USFL team okay and you
know I thought what a nice guy
mm-hm and then we walk out and Howard
says to me on the street he goes careful
of you I've never met anybody so lucky
to be born rich that's what yeah nailed
it and but the other story I want to
tell you the fun of your story I want to
tell you is driving in a limo with
Howard on a brutally hot New York day
yes
driving west and there is on the corner
a woman who's clearly a model you know
like a fashion model standing on the
corner waiting to cross the street mmm
and two cars in front of us almost
collide hmm and how it sticks his head
out the window and says honey you've got
to be more careful credit the girl was
hysterical laughing telling it like it
is Howard Cosell Peter Melman longtime
co-executive producer of Seinfeld and
writer right here in the Rochester okay
I got a list of some of your great works
with Seinfeld the apartment episode that
you wrote George wearing a reading
wedding ring to see what effect it has
on women did you ever do that no I
actually just made that up
you just made that up you didn't know
anybody who did anything good okay what
about the well Kramer's seizure to Mary
Hart somebody had that right in real
life correct I think that was Larry's
idea that he threw that you know like he
added into that that was a great idea
that was so he just threw that one you
know at first we weren't allowed to use
the Entertainment Tonight theme they
wouldn't let us use it
why I guess they were offended and the
show wasn't a big enough hit then but
when the show became a huge hit yes and
we went into syndication they let us use
the music
that we pushed we put in the music you
know for the syndicated shows right and
I've so I've met Mary Hart and she
thought it was hysterical the episode is
called the Good Samaritan because Jerry
trails a hit-and-run driver and then
falls in love with her and gets very
track yet is that something that you you
did yourself Peter no I made that up are
you serious yes I guess that's why
you're a terrific writer you know that's
the thing about fiction yes you got to
make it up
what about shrinkage do you make that
one up to shrinkage was I had this story
and I was struggling with it right and
Larry calls me over and says you know
what if George goes into the pool and it
caught and it's very cold and the girl
sees him and I said oh you mean like
shrinkage and Larry and his brilliance
says yes shrinkage and use that word use
it a lot you know Larry is so fireproof
in what he thought was funny it's
unbelievable and so he's like yes that's
the word and you just used it off the
top of your head what about Yatta Yatta
Yatta where did that one come from Peter
this is so strange but in 1988 or so
when I was a freelance writer in New
York I had an lunch with an editor from
a women's magazine and she said yada
yada yada a few times and I thought
that's kind of weird I never heard that
and somehow it came back to me
you know what ten years later nine years
later and I was thinking oh my god you
know if you say yada yada yada you can
gloss over all forms of sin you know and
so the idea just sprung from that and
you know the funny thing is I didn't
think yada yada yada would take off like
it did I mean in that same episode there
was an tide n tight that's right and
that's the one I thought that was gonna
go through the roof that's right because
Tim wanted converted
to Judaism and started telling Jewish
jokes yes and and that's when Jerry went
to confession right and that's my
favorite line in the whole episode is
that this offends you as a Jewish person
says the priests egos know and Friends
me as a comedian you know the funny
thing is you know the Ted Watt Tim
Watley what's his name I get Tim Watley
Bobby hi Bryan Cranston sure years later
I bump into him at a Dodger game when
and you know I congratulate him on
Breaking Bad night then I said to him
but God what happened to you you're not
funny at all anymore he's such a great
guy well he told a story here that be
the scene where he took a hit of the
nitrous oxide before putting it on the
patient came from didn't he say it came
from like the guy said why don't you
take a hit of the nitrous before you put
it on put it on and he's just and he
said he took away from that best ideal
wins is what he said doesn't matter who
it comes oh yeah that was why it was so
that was part of the best thing about
the show is that it was such a happy set
and everybody was like free to
contribute you know did you ever have
the showerhead that knocked you over is
that something to I'm trying to just
figure out what happened to you in life
and then I'm gonna put it on Seinfeld no
I try I once froze out my landlord and
the super because they wanted to change
my shower to a low-flow I couldn't have
that so you know like you take these
things and you bring him you know like
in the smelly car yeah you know that
happened to my friend Barry Landsberg
and he could not get the smell out but
you know it didn't attach itself to you
you know that's where the fictional part
comes you know if I realized that you
know if I could get everybody to go
through that car I could ruin their
lives for that day and that was the
point of the show is to like ruin
everybody's day and end up in a bad
place so you never had a girlfriend
there was a masseuse who refused to
massage you that never happened that
kind of happened
yeah that up where Jerry was just so
pissed that his girlfriend it was a
masseuse would not massage my friend the
massage he's going god she's amazing I'm
having all I'm getting is the sex oh my
god that is phenomenal yeah
Peter I could go on and on and on and on
but as they say that they've got the top
of the hour heart out
congratulations on hashtag me as well
that everybody can get and enjoy the
latest from in-between your very fertile
mind that people can go by where all
books are sold and thanks for coming on
here man it is perfect timing because
I'm actually on a verbal load management
so this I've just hit my I've hit mic is
my quota is that right yeah I'm unloaded
management from my publicist that would
have been a great episode load
management don't you think yeah that'd
have been a great uh person I keep
coming up with more episodes and I have
nothing to do with it verbal load
management that could be a great fantasy
team name for us right and Peter like
that or a rock band but you know what
Ben ladies and gentleman put your hands
together cuz I think James Dylan would
rather win a Grammy than an NBA
championship like given the choice he
would rather win a Grammy than than the
Larry O'Brien trophy for your New York
knickerbockers Peter I yeah he probably
rather you know win an award from the
Grand Dragon of the KKK oh my gosh that
is what we call a wormhole and that's
what we got by the way that's like
Costanza you're out that's it that will
walk out for more of the Rich Eisen show
tuned - audience Channel 239 under red
TV for free on BR live or download the
Rich Eisen show app